[Music]
oh what's up buddy
[Laughter]
[Music]
we got everything baby okay not enough
weight that's okay no we're gonna get
there
we got so literally not enough weights
for me to work out that's fine you
couldn't even you could do nothing with
this i mean i just like benched a
deadlift
deadlift absolutely not right because
not nowhere near enough weight yeah i'm
not even trying to brag right now yeah
but as far as like yeah bench we'll
figure it out
just a high reps could do some pull-ups
we do some pull-ups get on the
rope climb the rope i guess
we'll climb the rope oh saltbike is but
this is tough that's gangster yeah i
still love peloton you don't have the
screen so you just have a bike now yeah
and i also don't it's not even so i
never use it i actually just use it to
uh step up onto it to grab the pull-up
bar okay how many pull-ups can you go i
don't know man you don't do pull-ups i
do pull-ups i've never like met in in
college is my thing how did you do in
college college i had the well so at cu
i i did have the record for a while for
tight ends fullbacks
and then when i uh went to the pros
i trained with the
he's one of my best friends but he was
the head strength coach for the broncos
so i was like what's the record and i
set the record
and then i have the record for i don't
know six months
and then uh i came in one day and
they're like oh dude somebody broke your
pull-up record i'm like yeah it was like
i would i would tell anybody about my
[ __ ] pull-up record like somebody
broke it oh you're the [ __ ] who like
that new kid the [ __ ] broncos drafted
dude i'm like what kid that was tim
tebow
came in there saw your record destroyed
it and i was like oh hell no
he was like yeah uh if you're down to
work out with him he's here tomorrow so
he came tomorrow then we just you know
did our thing and then him got super
close yeah but he has the power of
christ on his side you don't i told him
that jesus christ helped him on two look
at this stance right did you see how he
was standing that's just me stretching
out
wow not a bad drive here though
we're in staten island staten island
baby but are we on an island
yeah yeah technically on island an
island of republicans
this is what this is baby dude i feel at
home yep staten island we're here in
staten island i'm in chrissy d's house
also your studio that's what it is baby
for both dude for both got blistex
medicated lip balm because i've had a
pain in my lower lip for a week
herbs words no i think it's hard
no herpes comes down blood tests right
dude what's up who's got better ankles
and comedy than brendan chop show them
those ankles baby
this outfit i feel like such a i feel
like a painter dude you feel like a new
yorker dude you literally look like you
look like just a big gay painter
[Music]
just finished flagrant two with schultzy
and akash and now i'm just chilling man
it's a great time on to the next one man
hopefully i survive new york
i'm in the elevator going to are you
garbage with my boys
kevin and foley i gotta be honest i'm
looking forward to this the most
because i don't know him that well and i
don't know what to expect these other
shows they're my buddies but these guys
this would be our first time meeting so
hopefully they're cool i've heard
nothing but great things so i'm excited
about it let's find out if i'm garbage
do you guys have a prediction what do
you think
i don't know he's i don't know he's
probably pretty classy now i don't know
though he just packed a lip so it's hard
to tell exactly he's down in the
scorecards he threw his rogue dip on the
table yeah oh yeah
that's my habit either way he's pretty
scary
he's got some ice on holy [ __ ]
thank you for being so open and honest
and the story with your dad's amazing
dude
that almost got me yeah that was [ __ ]
close
every time again i know you guys make
fun of me it's rare anybody asks me any
questions dude there is not a there's
not a a bragging bone in your body
you're one of the most humble people
dude flex on these dudes you [ __ ]
busted your ass for that [ __ ] that's
another thing it's like the
the trash is celebrated and so is the
success because people love seeing that
like and that's why i think a lot of
people they resonate with our show like
oh now that we are becoming successful
like it's so cool to see the journey for
sure so when you're like yeah i started
out wearing [ __ ] cleats and doing
dine and dash oh dude and now you're
like i'm [ __ ] doing well
from that your mom just trying to
[ __ ] make it work yeah my mom still
steals
i need everything i get super thick boy
what's up day two of the thick boy press
tour
new york's getting a lot of thick boy
i'm sick of talking but it's all good
because today we're in manhattan we're
in manhattan kind of getting my wits
about me where i'm at in new york now
i'm in manhattan today's a little
different than what you guys are used to
i'm not with a stand-up comedian i'm not
with an actor i'm with an entrepreneur
but just not anybody it's gary vee
that's right son the thick boy's on
garyvee i'm looking forward to this and
be different he's a brilliant dude we've
never met each other it could be really
awkward or it's going to be awesome
let's find out
hey how are you doing what's up brother
it's a pleasure to meet you man pleasure
yeah you're welcome yeah i'm great man
why don't you tell the vayner nation who
you are what you do give me a little
like comic book number one like a little
little four one origin story we'll get
into that yeah i'm gonna say holly got
it but uh yeah name's
i'm a stand-up comedian podcaster
uh
i'm the owner creator of uh thick boy
studios thick boy network where all my
shows are
based under that and
my number one profession is stand-up
comedian tour all over uh i just
released a special the gringo poppy on
youtube on my thick boy channel which
was shot by my team edited everything
fully integrated right everything man so
how do you think about that as a young
how old are you uh 38. so as a young
dude how do you think yeah but like you
know maybe not 12 but like you got you
got [ __ ] 60 years on earth so like 60
more mm-hmm
you're being generous
name the biggest grandpa you know with
cauliflowers in full sleep well that's
what i'm like that's what every grandpa
is going to look like in 60 years
at my size
i'm like a great dane dude no no no no
no no
do you have the mindset of like i'm
going to go in my 60s so [ __ ] go hard
i don't think i have that mindset i
think i'm realistic you know i i do take
care of myself modern medicine's insane
bro i'm hoping [ __ ] that everybody used
to die from yeah it's hard it's harder
to die from i think
i think there's i always think that my
level of ambition and competitiveness
there's a good side to it and a bad side
correct and i think for whatever reason
the circumstances of dna and parenting
and the luck of the draw i got lucky
like i want to be the greatest in the
world comma
whenever i don't achieve anything that
i'm like fully there for
there's a level of being content that i
[ __ ] went at it
that really gives me a little bit of
balance and i'm very aware that not
everyone that has the insanity of i
played basketball last night
i played once because i broke my foot at
the all-star game three years ago i've
only played once half-assed at the
garden the other day for a coin base
event this was the first time i played
basketball like three and a half years
four years last night for two hours you
would have thought this pickup game my
life depended yeah i wanted to win so
bad it was like bleeding out of my we
lost the first thing you can't shut that
off though it's just it's just in your
dna i can't but but
to
what you've achieved like
i'm glad that you're at that place at
such a young age because there are
people who never like love themselves
enough to go there correct yeah and i
think also like i wouldn't change
anything like of course if i would have
got signed by the buffalo bills and had
a five or six year career or in the ufc
if i would have became champ or won my
last fight which was eight years ago i
you know i wouldn't be where i'm at now
correct which is to me my true calling
but i have to go through
my journey to stand up and be in a
headline comic special were you a class
clown yes class clown i grew up in
aurora colorado which was predominantly
like a black neighborhood so to fit in
sports was the thing and it was a
double-edged sword for me because i was
really i wasn't big as a kid i was
smaller but i was really athletic so i
knew i could make friends by showing
them how good i was at football
but my
my my heart and my passion was saturday
live it was obsessed with snl snl robin
my mom would uh every saturday we
watched snl and then she always had me
watch robin williams so
she loved comedy she loved it that's why
i got my humor from my and she
introduced me all that stuff so
my heart wanted to be a comic but i was
really athletic it took me pla some
great places you also again based on
what i know about your athletic career i
didn't know i didn't know you you got to
go to camp obviously you know about the
ufc stuff um
i mean
that means in junior high or high school
you knew you had a shot what's up how
you doing good to see you my brother
tim allen's also from colorado but
claims detroit really shin gun kelly
also from colorado but claims ohio no
[ __ ] i don't know that was pure michigan
yeah machine gun kelly he moved from
denver and he's like 14. all he does is
claim ohio i'm like bro what's up with
denver four yeah 14 is pretty late 14.
you're from denver yeah
you're gonna get banned from this [ __ ]
today
yeah appreciate you guys
success dude
yeah i need to get more successful it's
never good i knew uh homeless pimp was a
big deal but i mean on the street man
you know people hey we take pictures of
us
[Laughter]
before you came in we're just like
betting on yourself is is not something
i'm ever going to do because i don't
have the confidence that you have i
don't know
i don't know the facial hair that you
have that's basically what it says i'll
bet on my [ __ ] self
i guess dude i don't really have a great
beard it looks like a printer of ink
[Laughter]
this is me answering the internet would
you rather spend the rest of your life
in a country music video or rap music
video well that's easy because country
music they're you know they're like in
the fields doing their [ __ ] it's all
white people and rap music listen
there's nothing better on this planet
than a fat ass let's be honest well
that's it just got done with bar stool
my boy kfc
i did uh ants answer the internet with
those crazy shenanigans i got a goodie
bag of clothes that i probably won't
wear but i do love bar stool
that's it man
i have nothing left i cannot talk
anymore so dear god please watch the
special it's the gringo poppy on youtube
it's on my think boy youtube channel if
you haven't seen it please go watch it
because i'm all over man and i came to
new york it started in la
that's it y'all that's it man so hope
you enjoyed it love you guys i'm gonna
go explore the city see you later
you